We're on problem 27.
And the question is, which
equation best represents the
graph above?
So before even looking at the
choices, let's see what we can
figure out about the graph.
So what's its y-intercept?
So if we said that this is the
equation of a line, we said y
is equal to mx plus b where m is
the slope and y is-- and b
is the y-intercept.
It's late, I'm getting
slightly muddled.
So what's the y-intercept?
Well when x is equal to
0, y is equal to 0.
So this is going to
be equal to 0.
The y-intercept is 0.
When x is equal to 0,
why is equal to 0.
So the y intercept is 0.
So we know that this has a form
y is equal to mx where m
is a slope.
Let's figure out the slope.
Slope is equal to change in y
for a given change in x or
change in y over change in x.
So when we increase x by 1, how
much are we increase-- or
decrease y by?
Well then y increases by 2.
So we could say that equals y
changes by 2, by plus 2 when x
changes by plus 1.
So we get the slope is equal to
2, so the equation of this
line is y is equal to 2x.
Which is choice B.
Next problem.
Which point lies on the line
defined by 3x plus
6y is equal to 2?
Well the best thing to do is
just probably to substitute
these numbers in for x and y
and see which one works.
So here x is 0, y is 2.
So let's see.
3 times 0 plus 6 times 2
is equal to 0 plus 12.
Doesn't equal 2, it equals 12.
This one doesn't work.
I'm just taking 3 times
x plus 6 times y and
seeing what it equals.
In this case, we have 3 times
0 plus 6 times y.
Plus 6 times 6.
Well that's 0 plus 36.
That doesn't equal 2.
Can't be that choice.
This one, we have 3,
this 3, times 1.
Plus 6 times this y.
6 times minus 1/6.
So let's see.
That's 3.
That's equal to 3.
And then, 6 times 1/6
is 1, but we have a
negative out there.
So it's minus 1.
That is equal to 2.
So that works.
3 times 1 plus 6 times negative
1/6 is equal to 2.
So our answer is C.
Problem 29.
Let me see if I need to cut
and paste this one in.
All right.
So yeah, I think it's
a good idea.
Let me see.
Copy and paste it.
Let me copy and paste the next
several problems. We could
just move-- be streamlined
about it.
OK, they all fit.
Good enough.
What is the equation of the line
that has slope of 4 and
passes through the point
3 comma minus 10?
So if the slope is 4, we know
that the line-- so just
rewrite it in slope y-intercept
form again.
mx plus b.
They're telling us that
the slope is 4.
So we know the equation of the
line is y is equal to 4x plus
the y-intercept.
And then we could figure
out the y-intercept by
substituting in this point that
they say it goes through.
So it goes through the point
3 comma negative 10.
So y is equal to minus 10
when x is equal to 3.
So 4 times x.
x is equal to 3.
Plus b.
So what is that?
That's minus 10 is equal
to 12 plus b.
We could subtract 12 from both
sides of this equation, and we
get minus 22.
Minus 10 minus 12 is minus 22.
This 12 obviously goes away.
Is equal to b.
So the equation of our line is y
is equal to 4x plus b, which
we just figured out
is minus 22.
4x minus 22.
That's choice A.
Problem 30.
The date in the table show the
cost of renting a bicycle by
the hour, including a deposit.
If hours, h, were graphed on the
horizontal axis-- let me
see if I can draw that.
So that is on the horizontal
axis I have hours, h.
So this is h.
And costs were graphed on the
vertical axis, so let me draw
the vertical axis.
So cost is on the
vertical axis.
What would be the equation of
the line that fits the data?
OK, so they just want to know
cost as a function of hours.
So let's see.
It's a linear relationship.
We could treat this just
like any other line.
So if we write it as
y equals mx plus b.
I didn't even have to do this.
So y is equal to mx plus b.
So m, or the slope, is equal to
change in y over-- or let
me write it differently.
Because we want it in terms of--
so we could write c is
equal to the slope times
the hours plus b.
Instead of x, we have hours, and
instead of y, we have the
cost.
So what's the slope?
Slope is equal to change in the
dependent variable, change
in cost, divided by change in
the independent variable,
divided by change in hours.
So let's see.
If when our hours increased
by 3, how much did our
change in c go by?
When we go from 2 to 5, so if
we say 5 minus 2, that's how
much we changed in hours.
That's delta h.
Then how much did we
change in cost?
Well it's 30 minus 15.
So it equals 15 over 3.
which is equal to 5.
So we figured out the slope.
Slope is equal to 5.
Now we just have to figure
out the y-intercept.
So this equation, we could
rewrite it as cost is equal to
the slope, which is 5, times
the hours plus whatever our
y-intercept is.
And then we just have to
substitute one of the points
in to solve for b, just like we
did in the previous video.
So let's substitute the point
when h is equal to 2, c is
equal to 15.
So the point 2 comma 15.
So when h is equal to
2, c is equal to 15.
c is equal to 15 when
h is equal to 2.
And now we can just
solve for b.
So you get 15 is equal
to 10 plus b.
Subtract 10 from both sides,
you get b is equal to what?
5.
So the equation of this line is
cost is equal to 5 times h
plus our y-intercept, or plus
our c-intercept we could say.
So plus 5.
5h plus 5, and that
is choice C.
And if you try it out
with these points,
it should all work.
OK, next problem.
Let me see.
I think this cutting and
pasting works out well.
I think I have time for
at least two more.
OK, let me clear this.
Clear this one right here.
Let me paste it in.
OK, it says, some ordered pairs
for a linear function of
x are given in the
table below.
It's kind of like
the last one.
Which of the following equations
was used to generate
the table above?
Well we could do the same thing
we did the last time.
We could say OK, this is going
to have some relation.
You know y is equal
to mx plus b.
It's going to be a line
and this is the
slope y-intercept form.
And they tell us it's
the linear function.
So that's why we can immediately
say that's going
to be a line.
There's no x squared or
anything like that.
So a good place to start
is just with the slope.
So slope is equal to change
in y over change in x.
So let's see.
When x goes from 1 to 3,
what does y go for.
It goes from 1 to 7.
So change in x is equal to
3 minus 1 or just 2.
And what's change in y?
7 minus 1.
So that is equal to
6 over-- oh, no.
Sorry.
Change in x was 3 minus 1.
Sorry about that.
3 minus 1.
So it's 6 over 2.
When x changes by 2-- that's
this 2, change in x-- y
changes by 6.
That's change in y.
So the slope is 3.
So the equation of our line is
going to be y is equal to 3x
plus some y-intercept.
And now we could substitute
some points in.
Let's substitute this one.
This 1, 1 seems easy.
So y is equal to 1 when
x is equal to 1.
So we get 1 is equal
to 3 plus b.
Subtract 3 from both sides of
this equation and we get what?
1 minus 3 is minus 2 is equal
to-- obviously, this
disappears, 3 minus 3.
So b is equal to minus 2.
So the equation of our line,
we have a slope of 3 and a
y-intercept of minus 2.
The equation is going to be
y is equal to 3x plus b.
Well b is minus 2.
So minus 2.
And that is choice C.
32.
The equation of line l is
6x plus 5y equals 3.
And equation of line q is 5x
minus 6y is equal to 0.
Which of the statements about
the two lines are true?
OK, let's see.
They have the same
y intercept.
They're parallel.
They have the same
x-intercept.
Lines l and q are
perpendicular.
Well I'll tell you how you can
identify perpendicular lines.
They have the negative inverse
of each other's slope.
But I don't know if that's going
to come into play yet.
I always find it easier to look
at these lines in kind of
the slope y-intercept form.
So let's do that.
So line l can be 6x plus
5y is equal to 3.
So if we were to subtract 6x
from both sides you get 5y is
equal to minus 6x plus 3.
And then you divide both sides
by 5 and you get y is equal to
minus 6/5 x plus 3/5.
So this is line l right here.
I'll do line q in a
different color.
So q is 5x minus 6y
is equal to 0.
So let's subtract 5x
from both sides.
You get minus 6y is
equal to minus 5x.
If you divide both sides by
negative 6, you get y is equal
to-- minus 5 divided
by negative 6.
That's 5/6 x.
Well, it actually looks like
D comes into play.
Because the slope of this
one is minus 6/5.
That's the slope of line l.
The slope of line q is the
inverse of that made negative.
At this point it's a good
thing to memorize.
I haven't proven
it to you yet.
If you want a line that has a
slope perpendicular to this
one, or a line that is
perpendicular to this one will
have a negative inverse slope.
So the inverse of this is minus
5/6 and the negative
inverse is plus 5/6.
So this is the negative
inverse of that.
So these lines are actually
perpendicular.
So that is D.
See you in the next video.